ก็สวัสดีค่ะน้าสวัสดีครับพี่เอ๋สวัสดี
ครับนักเรียน
อัดดีใจการเรียนภาษาไทยกันค่ะเจอกับครู
กับครูเอ๋นะคะคลิปผมนะคะวันนี้วันอะไรนะ
คะวันนี้วันนี้ใช่ไหมครับวันนั้นวันวัน
นี้วันพุธอ่ะๆวันนี้วันพุธนี้วันพุธวัน
พุธที่วันพุธที่สามค่ะวันพุธที่สามถูก
ต้องครับวันพุธที่ 3 เดือนอะไรคะครู
อาเตียนนี่อาเดือน
พฤศจิกายนนะครับเรียนวิกายลปีพตเท่าไหร่
คะผชปีนี้ปีพต
2564 ครับ
ปีกขอศ.เท่าไหร่คะ 5 ข้อ
นี้นะคะทีนี้อีก 2 คัน
564 ใช่ครับแล้วปีคศ
2010  21 หน้าใช่ครับควรตีขานิดนี้เวลา
โห
ที่ทุ่มหาเลาะ 5 เป็นเวลาล้างคืนอีกแล้ว
ไอ้พุ่มทำอ่า
ตอนนี้ตอนนี้เวลา
[เพลง]
9:00 นครับ
9:00 นครึ่ง
9:00 นครึ่งครับหาง
ง่วงนอนมากไหมกลัวดิยังไม่ง่วงเต๋าโอเคดี
ค่ะก็ยังไม่ง่วงนะครับเอกก็ยังไม่ง่วงกู
ที่ก็ยังไม่ง่วงอ่ะเรามาเรียนภาษาไทยกัน
หน้า
ถ้างั้นคลิปนี้ใช่ไหมคะก็คิดกลางคืนหน้าๆ
ที่นี่แหละกูอะตี้ถ้าไม่ง่วงคู๋วันนี้มี
อันนี้อ่ะเดี๋ยวกู Artist อยู่นะมีอะไร
ครับ a  Share  screen ก่อนน้ออ้าย Share
screen มา has  been
through
a  Tap  screen แล้ววันนี้เนี่ยกูเองมี
อันนี้จะเล่นกับครูอันตี้เดี๋ยวกูเอกกว่า
นี้เนี่ยไร
กูอันตี้โคโยตี้อันนี้กูอาจจะพูดเรื่อง
เลข 5 เลขครับปาร์ตี้อันนี้เลขอะไรคะอุ้ย
อะไรไหนครับนายมาเดี๋ยวกูเอกขอ
เอ้าทำไมเป็นอันนี้อยู่ตรงไหน
คู่ค่ะกูอ่ะรอรอรอรอ
กูเอ๋เดี๋ยวนะคะผัวตีนอนดูนักเรียนก็รอ
อ่ะ
จะรอดู
โอเคค่ะอันนี้เลขอะไรคะปูอัดหน้าก็
คอร์ด E เห็นกลมกลมๆๆ
กลมๆแบบนี้เลข 0 ใช่ไหมครับเดี๋ยวกูอีก
ว่าไม่สวยเลข 0
ค่ะ
เลข 0 นะคะ x ต่อไปเลขอะไรคะต่อไปนี่นี่
เลข
1 ครับเล็ก 1 ไหนของเลข 1 เลขต่อไปเลข
อะไรคะขออัดที่ไปหาต่อไปเลข 2 วาล์ว 2 นะ
คะเลขต่อไปเลขอะไรคะครูอาที่อ่ะต่อไปเลข 3
ครับ 5 เลข 3 นะคะชายไปเลขอะไรคะโทร Arty
หน้าแรกนี้เลข 4 นะครับเลข 4 นะคะเลขอะไร
คะครู Arty เล็กต่อไปเลข 5 ครับเลข 5 นะ
คะคะใช่แล้วเลขอะไรคะภูอาทิตย์และต่อไป
เลข 6 ครับเลขขบนะคะครับเลขต่อไปเลขอะไร
คะครูอัดตี้ออกไปเลข 7 เลข 7 นะคะได้ครับ
เลขต่อไปเลขอะไรคะกูอันนี้
เลข
8 ครับ 8 นะคะเลขต่อไปเลขอะไรค่ะต่อไป
เลข 9 ครับเลข 9 นะคะแป๊กเรียนก็รู้จัก
เลขนะคะ 1 อุ้ยโทรศัพท์ 0  0 ก่อนนะ
012 เนอะ
3  3
555 โคก
[เพลง]
5788 วาว 9  5 เลข 9 ครับ 5
9 ที่นี้ครู Arty เลขต่อไป
เลขอะไรคะ
น้าเล็กต่อไปเลข 10 ครับสิบนะคะนักเรียน
ปิดนะฮะ R ที่นิดตรงนี้กูเอกขอเปลี่ยนสี
แอปอ่าโอเคเปลี่ยนสีป้าหน่อยครับสีม่วงสี
ม่วงค่ะตอนนี้
092  0-9 ครับ
0-9 เราพูดวะล่ะหน่วยนะหมออ๋อหลักหน่วย
ล่างหน่วยแปลว่าถ้า 10
10  15 เลข 10 ถึง 99 เรียกว่าหลักอะไร
คะขอ
เลข 10 ถึง 99 เรียกว่าหลักสิบล่ะ 10 นะ
คะเด็กนะคะอ่ะอ่ะงั้นมาดูหลักสิบนะคะ 5
รักสิบมีอะไรบ้างครับหลักสิบนะกูเห็นลบนะ
คะซึ้งลบก่อน
ให้กูอะตี้พูดนะคะเลขอะไรคะและแรกนี้แลก
อะไรเลข 11 ครับเลขอะไรคะครู Arty ต่อไป
เลข 12 ครับเลข 12 นะคะเลขอะไรคะอ้าขอเลข
13 ครับเลขอะไรคะครู Arty เลข 14
เลขกับไปเลขอะไรคะอ้าเลข 15 ครับเลขอะไร
คะหารเลข 16 ครับเลขอะไรคะฮ่าๆๆแรก 17
เลขอะไรคะ 5 อันนี้เลข 18 ครับเลขอะไรคะ
อย่าเลข 19 ครับเลขอะไรคะครูอตี้
ว้าววันนี้มีเลข 2 กับเลข 0 เลข
20 ครับ 20 นะคะอ้างั้นต่อไปนะคะครู Arty
ครับผมอะไรคะอ่านี้เลข
21 ครับ 21 นะคะเล่นอะไรคะอ่าต่อไปเลข
ข้อ 2 เลข 22 เล่นอะไรคะอ่าต่อไป 23 ครับ
23 เลขอะไรคะ 5 ต่อไป 24 ครับ 24 เลข
อะไรคะหน้าต่อไป 25 ครับ 25 เลขอะไรคะ
หน้าเลข 26 ครับ 26 นะคะให้แล้วอะไรคะต่อ
ไปเลข 27 ครับ 27 เลขอะไรคะหน้าแรก 28
ค่ะจ้าใช่เลขอะไรคะอ่าต่อไปเลข 29 ครับจะ
ไปเลขอะไรคะว้าวเลข 30  30 นะคะอีกนิด
หน่อยนะคะมีเลขอะไรคะอ่าหัวหน้าวันนี้
31 ครับเลขอะไรคะ 5
32 ครับอื้อเอ่อ
เลขอะไรคะโอ้โห
เลขนี้เลข 40 ครับ
45 เลขอะไรครับกูอะตี้ต่อไปเลข 41 ครับ
41 ๆเลขอะไรคะไปถึงนี่เลข 50 ครับ 50
เรียนคะ
19 มาถึงตรงนี้ไม่ใช่ 2  08  20 ราคา 5
20 อันนี้ 10
20  30 น
45  55 นะคะไม่ใช่สองสิบไม่ใช่นะฮ่าๆแต่
3 ฮะโอเคสี่สิทธิ์โอเคของ 18
20 นะคะสิบถูกต้องแล้วก็ 21
22  23  24  25  26  27  28  29  30  30
หน้า 31  41  51 ลงไปนะคะๆ
พอนะเดี๋ยวกูเห็นลบนะ
จำได้แล้วรวนพี่ตั้มได้แล้วนักเรียนจำได้
ไหมไม่เป็นไรนักเรียนดูวีดีโอก็กลับไปดู
ใหม่ฮ่าๆดูๆโอเคกูเห็นลบนะคะอ้าก่อนเมื่อ
กี้คู๋เขียนนะคะ
ก็อุ้ย 10
มาถึง
99 เนี่ย
เป็นหลักสิบครู Arty คะถ้า
100 บาท
ถึง
199 หลักอะไรคะห่า
100 ถึง 100  99 หลักร้อยครับหลักร้อยนะ
คะๆหลักร้อยอ่ะถ้าอ่ะ
999 ขอโทษห่าอ้าวไป 99 ก็เป็นหลักร้อย
[เพลง]
100-999
หลักร้อยๆครับแล้วถ้า 1,000 บาท
ถึง 9000 อา
อ้า
999 ว้าวเป็นหลักอะไรคะถ้า 1,000 ถึง
เป็นหลักพันเขาหลักคันๆ 10,000
ถึง
99999 หลักอะไรคะอ้านี้ 10,000 ถึง
99999 เป็นหลักหมื่นครับหลักหมื่นแล้ว
พ่อกูเองมีอีกค่าามีอีกมามามีอีกแนงไฟโว่
1 แสนนะคะชื่น 999000
999 เป็นหลักอะไรคะอ้านี้ 1 แสนถึง
999999 เป็นหลักแสนครับหลักแสนอ้าต่อไป
ค่ะฮ่าๆบีอีกมีอีก 1 ล้านว้าวๆผิด
หน้า
1 ล้านครับ
ถึง
9999999 หลักอะไรคะหน้า 1 ล้านถึง
9999999 ล่างล้านครับและร้านค้าหลักล้าน
เสร็จก็จะมีหลักสิบล้านน้องใช่ครับสิบ
ล้านสิบล้านร้อยล้าน
[เพลง]
ครับ
ร้อยล้านโอเคนักเรียนปวดหัวและ 5 เยอะ
เยอะมากเลยมากเล่นเกมดีกว่าค่ะ
อ้อมเล่นเกมสนุกกว่าวันนี้ไม่เอาแล้วเลข
ตั้งแต่เลขอ่ะ
0 ถึง
ล้านหน้าศูนย์ถึง
ล้านปวดหัวเยาว์ๆ
Games  are
Games อันนี้เป็นเกมเดี๋ยวนะคะครูเห็นรถ
ก่อนอ้าวเกมอะไรครับครูเอ๋เกมเลข 5 อาอา
อาตี้ข้อเกมเลข 5 มาเล่นเกมเลขกันเลขครู
เอ๋จะคิดมีกระดาษเคมีกระดาษนะคะครู
อันติ้งสวัสดีก็มีกระดาษเคครับ
ผู้เอกเขียนก่อนนะคะได้เลยเขียนเขียนหน้า
เอกงั้นครู Arty ต้องต้องปิดตาก่อนอ้าปวด
อี้ไม่ดูใช่ไหมอ่ะเอาหลักหน่วยก่อนนะคะ
ล่ะหนูมวยอ่า
อ่ะกูอ่ะหลับตาก่อนดีมั้ยเห็นตัวตีปิดตา
ไว้นักเรียนดูนะคะนักเรียนดูอ้ะนักเรียน
ดูแล้วอ่ะกู Arty เปิดตาได้
เปิดแล้วครับกู Arty เลขที่ครูเอ๋เขียน
เนี่ยนะคะจะเป็นตั้งแต่
0 หน้าถึงอะไรครับ
ที่ 9 ขอดูสิค่ะอ้าวโอเคไปถึง
เก้าทัพปูอัดอิ๊ดต้องคิดครูเอ๋เขียนเลข
อะไร
ดีคิดว่าครูเอ๋เขียนเลข 6 เลข 6 จะแน่นอก
ใช่ครับอตตี้คิดคูเอกเขียนเลข 6 ใช่ไหม
ครับ
ไม่ใช่เลขปกไม่ใช่อ่ะงั้นเดี๋ยวไปให้กู
Artist เขียนตรงโน้นเนาะอ่า
เอกสต๊อกสกรีน
และครู Arty คิดไม่คบใช่ไหมคะไม่ขอไม่ใช่
เล็ก 6 แล้วเลขอะไรครับมากกว่าเลข 6 ค่ะ
กูอะตี้มากกว่าเลข 6 มากกว่าเลข 6 กวนตี้
คิดว่าน่าจะเป็นขอแลกเล่นอะไรแรก 8 ไหม
ครับเลขแป๊บอ้าได้ครับให้นักเรียนใช่มั้ย
เลขแต่เล่น 8 ไม่ใช่ถ้าไม่ใช่ไม่ใช่กับ
วันนี้ไม่ไปเลข 8  5 เลขนี้มากกว่าเลข 6
ก็น้อยกว่าเล็ก 8 ก็กูอันนี้ก็น้อยกว่า
เลข 8 ถ้าเลขที่รู้แล้วรู้แล้วอ่ะอ่ะเลข
นี้ต้องเป็น
เลขเลขอะไรเจ็บเท้า
เย้
เลข 7 หมู่หมู่กะเล็กเก็ตครับที่เป็นเล่น
เกม 7 คู๋ปิดตามั่งอ่าหา
Are  you  happy  Kids นะๆกูอันที่เขียน
ให้นักเรียนดูก็ได้อ่ากูโรตีเขียนเลข 1
เลขลงไปในนี้อ่ะมีนักเรียนเห็นหรือยัง
ครับเลขอะไรน้าาานักเรียนเห็นแล้วเดี๋ยว
กลัวที่จะลบออกนะครับห่าอ้ากู f เปิดตา
ได้ครับเปิดนะคะเนี่
ยเหถอดแว่นกูเอกก็มองไม่เห็นแล้วโอเคอ่า
เขียนเลขอะไรโอเคขวดตีใหม่บอกให้กูเอ๋ขา
High อ่าเลข 5 นี่เลยใช่ไหมเอกคิดเลข 5
เลข 5
มั้ยคะใช่ไหมเขาไม่เรียนไม่ใช่ไม่ใช่เลข
ถ้างั้นครู Arty ถ้าไม่ใช่เลข 5
มากกว่าน้อยกว่าเลข 5 ค่ะครัวตี้เขียน
เด็กน้อยกว่าเลข 5 ครับน้อยกว่าเลข 5 ใช้
กว่าใช่ครับ
น้อยกว่านี้ 5 เลข 1 ค่ะโอ้โห
ไม่ถูกไม่ใช่ไม่ใช่อาเล็กหนึ่งไม่ใช่ถ้า
ไม่ใช่ก็ต้องมากกว่าเลข 1 ใช่ครับครัวตี้
เขียนมากกว่ามากกว่าเลข 1 ครับแล้วก็น้อย
กว่าเลข 5 ใช่ครับน้อยกว่าเลข 5 เลขอะไร
ครับถามค่ะโอ้โห
ใช่มั้ยไม่ใช่
อ่านักเรียนนักเรียนช่วยกูเอกคิดจ่อยผู้
เอกตอบไม่ถูกครับเลขไม่ใช่ mifi เลขข่าว
ถามๆๆแรง
เขียน
น้อยกว่าเล็ก 3 ครับ
รู้
อ้ากู a รู้แล้วเหรอครับเลขอะไรครับ 2
ค่า
ถูกต้องครับตัวติ๊กเปลี่ยนแลก
2  5 ๆ
สนุกสองคน
ปิดตา
กลัวตีปิดตานะที่ปิดตานะคะอีกแล้วครับครู
เอ๋เอ๋ก็จะเขียนเลขนะคะ
เป็น 2 ตัวนะคะหลักสิบค่ะนักเรียนนัก
เรียนงานรักที่รักรีบครับโอเค
ort เปิดตาเปิดตาได้และถ้าเราใช่ไหมครับ
เปิดถ่านแล้วเอาหน่า
รัก 10 วอลาก 48 รักดิบก็คือ 40 นะครับไป
จนถึง
99  6 มีเลขเยอะเยอะมากเลย
หาขวดที่คิดเองเขียนเลขอะไรคิดว่าครูเอ๋
เขียนเลข
เขียนเลขเด่นเอ่อหยิบคิดว่าน่าจะเป็นเลข
อ้าย
ไปอ้ายขอไม่ถูกโอเค
แล้วครูเอ๋เขียนเลขมากกว่า 55 หรือน้อย
กว่า 55 ครับคู๋เขียนเลขมากกว่า 55 ผมขอ
มากกว่า 55 เสียกลัวที่เขียน 55 ไว้ตรง
นี้ค่ามากกว่า 55 ใช่ไหม 5 ขวดที่คลิปคิด
คิดไรอะไรว่าว่าคิดว่าครูเอ๋เขียนแลก
70 ม้า
miles  to  and
17  10 นี่มากกว่าหรือน้อยกว่าเลขที่ครู
เอกเขียนครับ kuai เขียนเลขมากกว่า 75
มากกว่า
70 ขอเคมากกว่า 70 กว่าตี้คิดคิดว่าครู
เอ๋เทียนเลข
น้าา
ro80 คอร์ป
หนังไม่ใช่อีกโอ้ไม่ใช่แปลกสิบไม่ใช่แล้ว
เลขที่ครูเอ๋เขียนมากกว่า 80 หรือน้อย
กว่าแปดสิบครับมากกว่าขาวบ้างออก็มากกว่า
80 ใช่ไหมอ่ะขวดอีกคิดอีกคิดผิดๆอ้ากู
เอกเขียนเลขเลขอะไรคะอ่า
โอ้ย
ไว้
โอ้ยยังไม่ใช่อีกยังไว้ Yeah หาแล้วเลข
ที่กูเอกเขียน
มากกว่าหรือน้อยกว่าข้อ 9  12 ครับโอเค
เขียนน้อยกว่า 92
น้อยกว่า
19  12 นะอาหารน้อยกว่าแผน 15 โอเคกว่า
ติ๊กคิดว่าหาครูเอ๋น่าจะเขียนเลขเลขอะไร
ห่า
โหใจแล้ว
ไม่ใช่ 86  5 แล้วกูเอกเขียนเลขมากกว่า
พื้นน้อยกว่า 86 ครับมากกว่า 86 อ๋อน้อย
กว่าเก่า 2 โอเคโอเคมากกว่า 86  5 ๆเกือบ
ไล่แล้วหัวติ๊กเกือบถูกแล้วนะครับคูเอก
เขียนเลขก๋วยติ๊กคิดว่าครูเอกเขียนเลขว่า
[เพลง]
เจ้าสิบไหม
ขอยังไม่คุย
ใช่ๆแล้วเลขที่กูเอกเขียนน้อยกว่าน้อย
ใกล้น้อยกว่า 90 ก็จะต้องเป็นก็จะต้อง
เป็นเลขกับ 5
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
55 เย้
งั้นเอาอีกหนึ่งเกมเนาะเดี๋ยวกูหาตากู
อะไรเขียนหลักพันห้าหูโคราชตาลอ้าโอเคได้
ครับปิดตานะปิดตาเลยครับอ่านักเรียนนัก
เรียนช่วยกันดูแล้วจำไว้นักเรียนอยู่เลข
แม่ครัวตี้จะเขียนขวดอีกเขียนแรกนี่ครับ
นี้รักพันนั้นนี่อ่ะ
นักเรียนเห็นแล้วใช่ไหมครับหลักคันอ่ะถ้า
นักเรียนเห็นแล้วเดี๋ยวครัวตี้อิลบออกลบ
ออกหาแล้วให้ครูเอ๋เปิดตาได้แล้วครับเปิด
อ้าวันดิ 5,000 บาท 5,000 บาทโอเค
แลกที่ครัวตีเขียนน้อยกว่า 5,000  5 น้อย
กว่า 5,000 ครับ
ๆครับน้อยกว่า
น้อยกว่า 5,000 บาท
3,000 บาท 3,000 บาทเอาแค่แลกที่ครัวที่
เขียนก็ยังน้อยกว่า
3,000 ครับ 2,000 บาทฮ่า
ๆๆ
ก็ได้ครับใช่ 2,000 บาทนักเรียนเมื่อกี้
ควยตี้เขียนเลขนี้ใช่ไหมครับอ่าอยู่กับ
ห้องเปลี่ยนเลข
ได้เร็วงั้นต้องมีละหมื่นหก
กว่าตีปิดตาก่อนนะฮะเรียนนักเรียนดูให้ดู
ให้ครัวตีด้วยนะเลขอะไรน่ะ comment
comment มาบอกด้วยขวดที่จะดูคอมเมนต์
เสร็จหรือยังเสร็จง่ายๆนี่กว่าที่ปิดตา
ก่อน
[เพลง]
นักเรียนนะคะดูนะคะ
น้าเลขอะไรครับมีเลขอะไรโอเคโค๊ดตี้ KS
แล้ว
โอเค
รักหมื่นนะคะอันติโน่หลักหมื่นใช่ไหมทัก
หมื่นเองขวดที่คิดว่าน่าจะเป็นเลขเอา
ครึ่งหนึ่งตัวที่เอาครึ่งหนึ่งค่ะครึ่ง
หนึ่งก่อนครึ่งหนึ่งนะครับก็ต้องเป็น
5,000 นะครับ
แล้วจะอ้าหมื่นอยู่ตรงกลางครึ่งหนึ่งห้า
หมื่นครับชาวเวอร์นะคะ
มากกว่าอ๋ออ๋อน้อยกว่า 50,000 เคเพราะ
ฉะนั้นเบียร์ตี้คิดว่า
20000 ครับ
20,000 บาทมากกว่า 20,000 ค่ะอ๋ออ๋อมาก
กว่า 20000
มีแต่ว่าน้อยกว่า 5,000 บาทอ่าเพราะ
ฉะนั้นก็จะต้องอยู่ที่
สามหมื่นครับ 30,000 ครับให้ไหมครับนัก
เรียนใช่ไหมไม่ใช่ใช่อ๋ออ๋อป้ามากกว่า 3
หมื่นใช่ไหมอ่ะโอเค
โอเคโอเคถ้าอย่างนั้นก็ต้องเป็นนี้นัก
เรียนคิดเหมือนครัวตีไหมว่าเป็นที่มือได้
ไม่งับห่า
กว่า 4,000 บาทมากว่าสี่หมื่นแปดน้อยกว่า
5 หมื่นนะมากกว่า 40,000 น้อยกว่า 50,000
บาทค่ะก็ต้องเป็นสี่หมื่น
5,000 บาทเอาเงิน 5,000 บาทไม่ทำนัก
เรียนใช่
อ๋ออ๋อมากกว่า 4 หมื่นหัวหน้าพันธุ์อีก
ล่ะครับไอ้ค่ะ
มากกว่า 40000  5,000 แต่น้อยกว่า 5
หมื่นกว่า 5 หมื่นถ้าอย่างนั้นต้องเป็น
47000 ครับใช่ไหมครับนักเรียนใช้ทำอะไร
แล้วครูอัดตีสวยขวดตีหน่อย
47000 ศูนย์ใหม่ถูกมากกว่าหรือน้อยกว่า
47000 ครับมากกว่าค่ะอ๋ออ๋อมากกว่า
47000 น่ะเพราะฉะนั้นก็ต้องเป็น
49000 บาทครับ
49000 บาทคะอ่าใช้น้อยกว่าค่าน้อยกว่า
ถี่ปุ่นเคยกว่า
น้อยกว่า 4 หมื่นเก้าพันนะโอเคมาเลยก็
ต้องเป็นอ้า
ที่เหลืออยู่ตัวเลขเดียวแล้วครับนักเรียน
แอบสี่หมื่น 8,000 ใช่ไหมครับ
สี่หมื่น 8,000 บาทมากกว่า 48000 บาทกว่า
4 หมื่น 8,000 น่ะโอเคโอเค
มากกว่า 4 หมื่น 8,000 ก็ต้องเป็นสี่พัน
อ้าสิหมื่น
8,000
500 ครับผม
มีหมื่นแปดพันห้าร้อยบาทมากกว่าค่ะมาก
กว่ากว่า
48500 ใช่ไหมครับอ่ะก็ต้องเป็น
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
49000 ครับสี่หมื่นแปดพันเก้าร้อยสี่
หมื่นแปดพันเก้าร้อยครับน้อยกว่าค่ะน้อย
กว่าอีกเหรอครับใช่ค่ะถ้าน้อยกว่าก็จะ
ต้องเป็นอ่าละ 40000
0807 ร้อยไหมครับ
น้อยข้างค่ะน้อยกว่าทีมอื่น
8700 อีกอ๋อถ้างั้นต้องเป็นอันนี้ไส้มาก
แล้วครับ 4,000
600 เย้
มากถ้าฝอยคออีก
โอเคถ้าอย่างนั้นต้องเป็นเป็นอะไรแต่ยัง
มากกว่า 48000  500 ไหมอ่าแล้วก็น้อยกว่า
48600 โอเคโอเคโอเคเดี๋ยวนะ
555  hey  hey มาเกือบแล้วครับนักเรียน
สู้ๆครับสู้ๆอะตี้ Arty สู้สะอาดผ่อน
r550 ครับขอ
2550 น้อยกว่าค่ะครูอัดตี้น้อยกว่านี้
อีกโอเคจะต้องเป็น
48000  500 บาท
45 น้อยกว่าค่ะ
โอเคได้แล้วครับอาเป็น
30 ครับน้อยกว่าค่ะ
สิบเขามากกว่าค่ะโอเคถ้างั้นก็ต้องเป็น 15
ครับมากกว่าค่ะโอเคเกือบแล้วครับ
ประกาไปไหนเอ่อ 17 ครับกว่า
59 ครับมากกว่าค่ะอ่ะมากกว่าเดือนนะยี่
สิบล้อ 25 ครับน้อยกว่าค่ะใกล้นักเรียน
ยี่สิบยี่สิบเฉยๆครับ
ฮะโอเค
23 ครับน้อยกว่าโอเคถูกต้องน้อยกว่า
อันนี้ถูกต้องแน่นอนวะ
21 คู่ R5 ถูกต้องครับอ้ากลัวตี้สนุกดี
ครับได้เดาเดาไปอ่าจนหู่ๆโอเควันนี้เวียน
สวัสดีค่ะวันนี้นักเรียนก็เรียนตัวเลขนะ
คะเรียนเลขอะไรบ้างคะเลขโหรสูนี้เขียนน้อ
อ้ายครับได้ครับเขียนได้ครับอ่านักเรียน
ก็เรียนเลขสู่ 0 นะครับ
1  2  2  3  3  4  4  4  4  5  5  6
เย้
นะคะแล้วนักเรียนจะรู้จักหลักสิบล้อหาใช่
ครับหลักสิบเก้าสิก mele  f10 ถึง 99 นัก
เรียนก็ล้วนฉันเล็ก 2 กับ 0 เราพูด 20 นะ
คะได้ว่า 20 นะคะ 20 นะคะถ้าเป็นสองหนึ่ง
ก็ 21 ใช่ครับ 21 น
31 ได้ครับ
31 ค่ะกาก 41 นก็ 41  51  61  7  11
แล้วก็รู้จักหลักร้อยหลักร้อยอะไรคะฝาก
ร้อย
ถึง 999
49  5 นี้แทนหลักร้อยครับอ่าแล้วก็หลัก
ครรภ์ค่ะถ้าเป็นหลักพันรับพันก็จะเป็นเลข
1,000 บาท
ถึง 9,000
999 วันนี้หลักพันแล้วก็หลักหมื่นค่ะ
หมื่นหลักหมื่นก็จะเป็นตั้งแต่ 10,000
ถึงเก้าหมื่นเก้าพันห้า
999 ครับแล้วก็หลักแสนภาพแหลนครับถ้า
เป็นหลักแสนก็จะเป็น 1 แสนน่า
ถึง
[เพลง]
999999 ครับและสุดท้ายหลักล้านล่าสุด
อย่าหลับหมานี่ครับหลักนั้นก็ตั้งแต่ 1
ล้านบาทครับอ่า 1 ล้านไปจนถึงนะครับ 9
ล้านนะ
999900 นะครับ
599 ครับโอเคค่ะ
วันนี้เนาะ
10:00 น 10:00 นแล้วหรอโห
22:15 น
ก็กู Arty ก็ง่วงนอนแล้วเนอะอ่ากูเองไอ้
ยังนอนละอ้าวโอเคนักเรียนรู้จักตัวเลข
แล้วรู้่กับครูอาร์ทตี้ต้องบ๊ายบายก่อนนะ
คะเดี๋ยวคราวหน้ากลับมาเรียนภาษาไทยกับ
ครูเอกกับครัวตี้กันใหม่ในช่อง component
สเบอร์ไทยวันนี้หน้าเราทั้งสองคนนะครับลา
ไปก่อนครับหาสวัสดีครับพี่เก๋อ่ะสวัสดี
ครับนักเรียนที่อ่านเรียนบ๊ายบาย